[Music]
well hello there river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 216 chapter 29 primary colors
now this is the first episode that we've
had in a while that reminds us of the
fact that these kids are actually still
in high school so I'm embracing my inner
jock with my look today whoa now I'll be
dropping three secrets about primary
colors in just a bit but first let's
take a look back at your hisses and
kisses from the comments of episode 215
chapter 28 there will be blood
kicking things off Phoenix Lestrange
says kisses to Shoni Tony was holding
Cheryl's hand at the will reading and it
was absolutely adorable as for the
comment made by Claudius I think it was
hilarious especially Cheryl's reaction
Oh hisses - not enough bug head I get it
solving crimes is important but what
about bug head and hisses - Fred for
thinking that building a prison was such
a horrible idea it isn't as bad as
everyone thinks it is well Phoenix
apparently photo Sanel agrees with you
because she wrote am I the only person
who doesn't understand the problem with
Hyrum wanting to build a prison the
sheriff's station isn't that good
anyways and a group of teenagers solved
a murder mystery that they couldn't
overall I think it would be good for
Riverdale please tell me your thoughts
if you disagree I'll admit it's not
ideal meanwhile Alice Bell posted I feel
like I'm the only one who really doesn't
like Ronnie anymore I just feel like
she's starting to be employed by her
parents well Simon walls has the same
thoughts because they wrote and in all
caps I really want Veronica to get away
from her parents
Veronica is a good person but her
parents are making her bed when you guys
write in all caps that's kind of how I
imagined your boy so sorry and following
on the all-caps train Bernice grew Dino
said okay but does anyone think the twin
is the dad oh are you referring to the
blossom twin Claudius yes someone else
does think that in fact Jessica Naru
dished the twin is fake Clifford blossom
is actually back because he faked his
death and made up that twin stuff and
got his mom to go along with it now I
don't know about you guys but if
Clifford blossom was really alive then
he would have had to perform some
serious trickery to pull that one off
but to quote Madeline patch herself
anything can happen in Riverdale as I
was saying and while we're on the theory
kick nameless simmer weighed in on chick
saying I don't think he's some crazy
random person who's pretending I think
he for a fact is chick and the DNA test
that they were looking for had blossom
blood which he doesn't have which also
supports the theory that he is the
lovechild between Alice and espy but
lastly blanca la banda ria gave us my
favorite comment of the week with her
theory that the mysterious character Ben
is actually alice's son not chick you
mean hot dog dude dogs oh my gosh well I
would love for that to be true now after
all if you guys will remember Riverdale
creator Roberto aguirre-sacasa told me a
few weeks ago that Ben aka hot dog dude
we're out of dogs is going to continue
popping up in Riverdale and then have
that super secret meeting with chick at
the Coopers so maybe they're in on this
together what do you think rubber babes
head down to the comments and tell me
your thoughts on this chick and Ben
theory now let's focus on this week's
episode because as you can see from the
promo it looks like it's gonna be a
scream now it's gonna be filled with
Cooper family confrontations
Veronica tears and random celebrity
cameos I'm here to endorse her my any
large oh and if you slow that promo down
you guys it's the return of Reggie
mantle but it doesn't look like he's
having that great of a week and now back
by popular demand here are three cheeses
about chapter 29 primary colors here we
go number one a friend of me will stab
another in the back you won't see it
coming
number two pack your bags because
someone's moving out and someone's
moving in and number three the last 30
seconds of the
episode will make you want to throw your
TV out the window and then plot the
murder of a fictional character at least
that's what I did and there you have it
thank you so much for joining me for the
Sweetwater secrets preview show and be
sure to join me again after you've
watched episode 216 chapter 29 primary
colors for a brutal round of hisses and
kisses plus get excited because we have
a brand new segment called catfight
coming in this week Sweetwater secrets
after-show and you won't want to miss
the ferocious showdown as always please
give this video a like and hit the
comments to see if you can decipher my
three clues then head over to my Twitter
page because I'm going to be
interviewing the Riverdale cast this
weekend I'm going to be asking them your
questions straight from my feed
so I'll tweet you later river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]